hi um so I flew in from Australia the
day before yesterday I'm not saying that
I am the most jet-lagged person here but
I would appreciate it if you could all
just put in a little bit of effort to
laugh at my jokes that would really make
things easier for me so the event loop a
couple years back here at this very
conference a guy by the name of Phil
Roberts did a talk called what the heck
is the event loop anyway if you haven't
seen it I highly recommend you check it
out it's on the Jay s conf YouTube
channel it's pretty [ __ ] exciting
[ __ ] catches on fire um in case you
haven't seen it though it's a really
good overview of the event loop the
different components and how they work
together if you haven't seen it we'll do
a quick overview of the things that are
relevant for today and then we're gonna
do a bit of a deep dive into some
specific parts of the event loop so you
can think of the event loop as like the
main function of the browser it's just
an infinite loop it's gonna grab a task
off the task cube and it's gonna run
that task which is great but what's the
task sir a task is how JavaScript gets
run if we have a bit of a script tag
like this we can see that a JavaScript
in there the browser's gonna pause this
script tag and it's gonna create some
tasks so the code with the dark
background is gonna be a task when it
gets run it's gonna create a variable
it's gonna do something and it's gonna
register this event listener and then
whenever the browser gets a keydown
event the bit of blue is gonna run as a
task so everybody JavaScript the runs as
a task it could be a script it could be
a callback
what is execute tasks do and look it
just runs the code it's really not
important if you want to know what fills
talk but what about the task queue
that's what we're gonna talk about today
we're gonna have a look at task queues
in the context of browsers
and we're also gonna have a look at nerd
and we're gonna have a real quick look
at web workers cool so what's a task
cube and what's it for
so your task queue is where your code
goes while it's where your JavaScript
goes while it's waiting to execute so
like before we could pause the script
tag we could have a callback on a click
event we could have a callback on the
set timeouts or an xhr request they're
all gonna go into our queue there and
they're going to get executed important
thing is it's a cute so things are gonna
get executed in the order that they
arrive first in first out the other
important thing is that a task is going
to run from start to finish right
there's no interrupts in JavaScript you
don't have to worry about concurrency or
locking or synchronization or any of
that rubbish it's super easy go so
that's our event loop it turns out
though it's a little bit more
complicated than that you see the task
queue works in conjunction with the
rendering pipeline the rendering
pipeline is what's responsible for
painting things in the browser window so
you make changes to the Dom you update
your style then the rendering pipeline
runs and shows it on the screen so the
rendering pipeline can run after task
finishes sauce finishes rendering
pipeline can run but browse is a pretty
clever right and they didn't like to do
work that they don't have to do and
there's really no point running the
rendering pipeline unless the screens
about to refresh so your average screen
right refreshes 60 times a second once
every 16 milliseconds
so we're on a task the runner your
pipeline is going to wait about 16
milliseconds before it runs if it's not
obvious this is the slowed down version
it turns out it's hard to see things at
60 frames a second obviously sitting
around doing nothing all that time is a
bit of a waste so in reality the browser
is gonna run a bunch of tasks and then
run the rendering pipeline
the important thing here though is that
the rendering pipeline can't run until
the task finishes so if you've got a
task that takes a really long time the
rendering pipeline has to wait a couple
of milliseconds here and there probably
isn't gonna matter but if you've got
tasks that take a lot more than 16
milliseconds your webpage is gonna start
dropping frames it's gonna start running
like this if you do have a long running
tasks you can split them up so you can
create new tasks using something like
set timeout you can just run the first
part of your task and then run the rest
later on or you can use web workers
because that's literally what they're
for so now our event loop looks a bit
like this we're gonna run an infinite
loop we're gonna pick a task off the
task queue and we're gonna run that task
and then if we're ready to repaint well
repaint that's cool right it turns out
though it's a little bit more
complicated than that if you haven't
looked at the the spec which I'm sure we
all do in our spare time you'll see that
an event loop can have one or more task
queues now I have to say at this point I
thought what I'll do is I'll have a look
at some actual browser code I'll go in
and I'll see like how chromium does toss
queues how manages them whatever but I
have to level with you I'm a JavaScript
developer and it turns out that C++ it's
mostly punctuation and the word delegate
I no idea what's going on there so
instead we're gonna look at a
theoretical browser with multiple task
queues now to be clear this is actually
the example that's given in the spec of
having multiple task queues so it's not
like I just made it up somebody else
made it up so this Q R this browser
sorry it prioritizes mouse click events
so it's got two task queues there it's
got one where a mouse click events are
gonna go
and it's got another cube where
everything else goes and this is real
simple it's it's just like the the
business class line at the airport it's
gonna run all of the tasks in the mouse
click cube and then it's gonna run the
test in the other queue and it doesn't
affect the rendering pipeline that's
still gonna run after each task if it
wants to go so it's super simple it
doesn't have to be like that right the
browsers can actually execute the queues
in any order that they like so we could
have taken 2 off the mouse click event
off the mouse click queue and then 3 off
the other queue or whatever we like they
can go the queues can be executed in any
order but the queue still still do still
have to be queues so the tasks have to
be executed in the order that they
arrived first in first out also tossed
from the same source have to go in the
same queue so all of our mouths quick
events have to go in that queue node for
example uses a specific queue for
timeout events so all of the timeout
events have to go in that queue so this
is how our event loop looks now we've
got an infinite loop we're gonna pick a
queue we're gonna grab a task off that
queue and run it and then it was time to
repaint will repaint go so this is still
pretty straightforward right it turns
out it's a little bit more complicated
than that there we also have micro tasks
what's micro tasks for the purposes of
this 20-minute talk a micro tasks is a
promise so there are other things that
generate micro tasks but like 99.9% of
the things you're going to do it's going
to be promises so our micro task queue
is in yellow there next to the rendering
pipeline and we have a bit of code it's
gonna run we have a promise that
resolves it goes in the micro task queue
now the micro task queue has a couple of
special properties first of all it runs
after every task so you finish the task
then you run the micro tasks you
even if the rendering pipeline would
like to run it has to wait until the
micro task queue finishes if we have
multiple tasks in the micro task queue
they're all gonna run and if we add more
while we're running it those all have to
be run too so this has some important
implications for how things run let's
have a quick look at the difference
between her tasks run and how micro
tasks run sir this bit of code generates
tasks I'll click the button it's gonna
print out the number of tasks that it
has run and then it's going to generate
another toss which is going to print out
the number of tasks that's run and so on
and so forth infinitely you can see here
we can start it running it's counting
tasks but everything is great I can
still enjoy it to the page I can select
text I can click stop I can't click to
start again because I didn't implement
that but if we look at the same thing
with micro tasks things are a bit
different
so if I start so this is the same code
right it's creating a micro task which
is going to print out the number of
micro tasks that have run and then it's
gonna create another micro task and it's
just gonna keep looping the same as the
set so I'm at example about with
promises so I click start promising we
can see immediately everything has gone
to [ __ ] the button has clicked but it
hasn't unclicks right the cursor which
probably can't see there it's still the
little hand I can't select text I
definitely can't click stop which
wouldn't have helped because I didn't
implement it anyway it's like I knew
what was going to happen this pages is
kaput if we wait a little bit longer
Krim will realize and tell us but I
don't have that kind of time
so what happened that exactly like we
saw in the example we're stuck just
dealing with the micro tasks you so the
rest of the event loop is booked we
can't rerun to the page we can't do
anything else we're just stuck in the
event loop no stuck in the micro task
you
so yeah cool so this is our event Luke
looks now it's still an infinite loop
we're gonna pick a queue we're gonna
pick a task of that queue and we're
gonna run it and then as long as there
are micro toss to run we're gonna do
micro tasks and then once that's done if
it's time to repaint will repaint go so
this is starting to look a little bit
complicated but it turns out it's
actually just a little bit more
complicated than this we also have the
animation frame callback cube which I'm
gonna call the animation cube because if
I keep saying animation frame callback
you this talk is not gonna get finished
in time for lunch sir you can add things
to the animation cube by calling request
animation frame and passing it a
callback why would one do such a thing
well I'm using it here to run the
animation of the browser running into
the the browser window running into the
pipeline so I have my browser window and
my pipeline I remove a cloth which
resets the the frame and then I add the
the slide class to the window which
gives it a which makes it slide down
through the magic of transitions if I
did it like this like I said before
browsers a clever and they like to be
helpful if I wrote this code the browser
would look at it and say you've removed
the cloth and then you've just added the
same class back again
that's the same as doing nothing so
let's just do nothing so instead I have
to make sure that the things occur after
so I need three one I need the browser
to reach the window to refresh and then
I need to do the next thing and we have
a look at how that works and we've got
our animation queue there in green
beside the rendering pipeline so I've
got my scripts running and I call
requestanimationframe which adds
something to the animation queue you can
see it's going to sit there and
things gonna happen until we're ready to
repaint then we'll run the animation
cube and then we'll we'll repaint the
browser like the micro tasks you the
animation queue has a couple of special
properties so if I have multiple things
in the animation queue when it's ready
to run I'm gonna run all of those things
but if I add more things to the
animation queue while it's running I'm
not gonna run those guys the reason for
that is if you're creating animations
you want to say this is what I want to
do in this frame and then you want to
set up what's gonna happen in the next
frame but you don't want to run it right
you want to wait until the the window is
refreshed go sir this is what our event
loop looks like now it's an infinite
loop we're gonna pick a queue we're
gonna grab the first task of that queue
and we're gonna run the task then as
long as there are micro tasks we're
going to run all those then if we're
ready to repaint we're gonna grab all of
the the animation tasks that are
currently in the queue and we're gonna
run all of those and then we're gonna
repaint and that is as complicated as it
gets but what about nerd well first of
all some good news
nerd is a lot simpler than a browser
it's got a script pausing events right
you're not picking JavaScript out of
HTML all over the place you just give it
a JavaScript file and it runs it there's
no users clicking on [ __ ] all over the
place you don't have to worry about
animation frame callbacks because
there's no rendering pipeline
there's also another important
difference with node the browser event
loop is like a merry-go-round it just
keeps going round and round and round
and round the nerd event loop it's more
like a rollercoaster it's gonna run
through one loop and there's more stuff
to do it'll run through another loop but
once it's done that's it it's done
so the note event loop node has three
cues that are intruded interesting
enough to talk about today it's got one
cue for all of your event callbacks so
your xhr requests your disk reads and
writes although that kind of stuff is
gonna go in the first queue the second
cute they're called phases in there so
the second phase is the check phase
which I will get to in a minute and the
third phase is your timers so that's all
of your callbacks for set timeout and
set interval or we're going to go into
that third queue so node is going to run
everything in the in the event callback
you it's going to run then everything in
the check queue once that's done it's
going to run everything in the timer
queue many of there's more stuff it'll
loop back around and run through the
queues again but as soon as there's no
tasks any in any queues and there's no
events waiting anywhere it'll just it'll
finish it'll end so how do you add stuff
to the check phase you can add things to
the check face queue by calling set
immediate and passing it a callback set
immediate is basically the same as set
timeout with a time of zero but because
of the way the queues work if you call
set timeout with the time of zero and
you call set immediate you're set
immediate is going to run first cool
nerd also has promises just like the
browser and no promises work just the
same as browser promises after each task
finishes will run the Micra the the
promise micro task queue soup easy node
also has another micro task queue which
is the next tick you you can add things
to the next tick you by calling process
next tick and passing a callback it
works just the same there's nothing
really interesting there the major
difference is if you have both promises
and next sticklebacks all of your next
tick callbacks will run
any of your promises but that's pretty
much it so they only only really new
things different things in nerd set
immediate and processed up next stick if
you have trouble remembering how they
work it's easy set immediate does
something on the next tick process next
tick does something immediately simple
why are they named like that it turns
out naming things are hard you guys all
know the two hard problems in computer
science right casein validation and
naming things and off-by-one errors
so this is our node event loop it's only
going to run while they're still tasks
it's gonna pick a queue and then while
that queue has more tasks it's gonna
grab the next task in that queue it's
gonna run that task then while the next
tick you has more tasks it's gonna run
all of the next tick queue tasks and
then while the promised cure has more
tasks it's going to do all the promises
so that just leaves webworkers anyone
who's not familiar with Australian
wildlife this is a red back spider
unlike most of journey and wildlife
they're not that dangerous nobody's died
from a red back spider bite since the
50s probably don't get bitten by one
though
goats are web workers web workers turn
out to be dead simple each each um web
worker runs in its own thread it's got
its own event loop it's got its own
stack it's gonna throw in tasks you
everything just runs on its own it's
even easier than nerd so there's no
script tags again you just passed it a
JavaScript file there's no user
interactions web workers aren't allowed
to manipulate the Dom so you don't have
to worry about any animation frames or
anything like that if we have a look
temer we can see we can generate tasks
we can call set timeout we can make xhr
requests we can send and receive post
message events so if post message is how
your web worker communicates with the
browser window and we can make promises
it's that's it it's just really easy um
yeah that's the event loop right things
to remember long running tasks will make
your webpage run like a wonky capped but
promises and next tick tasks they can
make it run like a dead cat so make sure
you break your tasks up into small
pieces and don't have infinitely
recursive promises and next tick tasks
nerd is a bit different to the browser
it's gonna run through the event loop
only as long as there are things to do
it's got those three specific tasks and
it's got a set immediate and process
thought next tick and webworkers they do
their own thing right they're all in
their own event loop they completely
separate from anything else that's going
on I remember the event loop is more
exciting than you can possibly have
imagined thank you
[Applause]